we live together and despite that fact
we've barely seen each other for
probably two months now yeah well
because if I'm traveling you're home if
you're traveling I'm home so now now
we're finally reunited and feels good in
that time if like it's that's such a
long amount of time for two people to be
a part that life has happened in the
interim uh I hit a million Subs recorded
with Bumstead Sam Harris hosi went to
that gym shark event
you traveled to the UK Korea Japan then
came back then went to the CrossFit
Games for the entire time Rogan posted a
piece of your content on the show that
he did reacted to a piece of content on
the show I think you've broken some more
subscriber milestones and now I'm about
to leave for another two weeks so this
is like a brief period like everybody
else might not care I haven't caught up
with you so I want to know what what
what the headlines have been from the
last couple of months of your life
uh just more the same like it's the
content game you you know it I know it
it's very it's what's cool is like for
for those of us for people who aren't in
the content game basically everyone
who's listening to this um it's very
interesting to find people who are also
in it and then live with that person so
it's like uh I kind of get motivated by
your work and I feel like sometimes you
check in and you're like holy [__]
Zach's done something pretty big here um
but yeah it's just more the same like uh
getting crazy interviews meeting people
who so Ben Smith the winner of the
CrossFit Games back in 2015 or 2016 or
something maybe 2014 I forget um he was
one of my heroes in CrossFit I'm at the
airport and he walks up to me he like he
literally makes a beline for me goes hey
man I love your stuff on YouTube I'm
like funboys over you bro I have yeah so
so we like clicked immediately I went to
uh Virginia Beach and I actually just
just did a training session with him I
didn't even cover it or put it on my
YouTube channel um it was just so cool
for things like that to happen and I
know that that's been happening to you
like because I knew you before you would
have ever had a chance to have been on
Rogan uh let alone be friends with Rogan
so it's really really fun you just had
an episode on Rogan where some episode
got responded to what was that I haven't
watched that episode yet I saw your
screenshot of it but I haven't seen it
what were they reacting to and what they
say so it was uh Alexander Kellan who is
uh one of the most dominant athletes
period of all time uh I think he went
over a decade without losing in
wrestling so he's a Greco Roman wrestler
and he was a super heavyweight I think I
yeah so that's like um kind of like the
unlimited class but he was picking up
guys like he's picking up the super
heavyweights and that's not typically
the thing um he had you know what his
main move was the Kellin lift where it's
like you hold someone around the waist
but upside down and then you can throw
them or whatever um he was so good and
so athletic that some athletes would
forfeit before even going up against him
they would literally forfeit before
going up against him and uh he the the
numbers that he hit in the weight room
this is why it was so interesting to me
the numbers that he hit in the weight
room the size of this guy and then his
athleticism he could do back flips he
could do the splits he was about like 63
280 lbs in his prime like right around
300ish maybe at his heaviest uh but he
was a freak of nature and I made a video
on it and it kind of popped off a little
bit it exploded late you know how videos
do that like they're just kind of
whatever and then like a year later they
just go uh that happened to this video
and then I posted it a part of it to my
Instagram and Rogan saw it on my
Instagram followed me on Instagram which
was was pretty cool uh and then recently
he was talking with someone I forget who
it was but sad yeah Gad sad and he was
like have you heard of this guy Kellin
go on YouTube you search Alexander
Kellin whose video pops up it's your
boy's video it's right there let's go so
they're pulling it up watching how did
that how did that feel it felt good but
it was also like you know it's not like
they went oh this guy Zack tender made a
really good video it wasn't about
productive exactly I just provided the
the info for them however uh the the
follow on Instagram was much bigger deal
for sure yeah that adrenaline dump is
one hell of a drug um yeah I I think
it's interesting like finding cool
stories think about um coffeezilla when
he was pumping out stuff more frequently
what was exciting about him was he was
Finding crypto scams and and grifters
and stuff from projects that you'd never
even heard of it wasn't always s bankman
freed in FTX or Logan Paul's crypto Zoo
it was people that you didn't even know
about so it's like it's like a um
literally like a documentary that
teaches you about something that you
would have never known about previously
so I think that's that's what's cool and
obviously when you have someone that
goes narrow and deep like you do or
Derek in sport specifically or
pharmacology you end up with really
interesting ideas so yeah man one of the
things that we're going to talk about
today is this new
transgender athlete division in some
strength sports but first we need to
talk about our old friend Billy
McFarland guy that did fire Festival so
for the people that aren't familiar
fraudster Billy McFarland relaunches
fire Festival from behind bars with
$8,000 tickets his rerun of the event
which previously ended in disaster in
2017 is set to take place in December
next year so he was in jail for quite a
while it seems like he's out now and he
puts this video up in a bathrobe looking
like the most aristocratic like New York
wanker that you can think of and he said
this is a big day it has been the
absolute wildest journey to get here and
it all started during a seven-month
stint in solitary confinement I wrote
out this 50-page plan of how it would
take this overall interest and demand in
Fire and how it would take my ability to
bring people from around the world
together to make the impossible happen
long story short he has released tickets
first sale of tickets have sold out for
another fire Festival in the Caribbean
which I I think is where it was last
time Pablo Escobar's Island MH and he's
just running it back we'll just do it
again yeah I have a question so he wrote
a 50-page
Manifesto or something in Sol like a
business number one thing my brother in
Christ it's not that deep it really
isn't you got a bunch of models I'm
sorry you got a bunch of models and you
know kind of aish celebrities to post an
orange photo and that but this was
before viral was like so saturated
online and this idea of fire Festival
exploded it was over your head you
didn't cancel it quick enough and you
stole a bunch of money from a bunch of
people it's not that deep oh what so so
you're Reinventing yourself doing this
thing I'm you know it's like you're just
trying to do another Festival like it's
been done now since Ted kazinski this is
isn't Like You [__] trying to fix the
problems of the world yeah I dude I
don't know I've got such interesting
thoughts about feelings about Billy
McFarland because I know for a fact that
if he'd managed to pull off the fire
Festival people even if he even if it
just wasn't a complete disaster even if
it was remotely acceptable people would
have hailed him as a marketing genius
because Chris yeah this is what we all
me and you always end up talking about
this we love winners the world loves
winners and it doesn't even matter how
evil how bad they are if they win you
you have to there's a decent amount of
people who are just going to be like
yeah but dude look at the money look at
the you know he he he fulfilled he came
back we love a comeback story it's like
well that can't you can't forgive and
forget everything like that I mean this
is this is Andrew Tate this is um you
know Logan
Paul uh Jake
Paul the Logan Paul rug pool the with
with the crypto
zoo I think like two weeks later or four
week later he did a deal with Dana White
in the UFC and now he's doing a deal
with uh you know Bayern Munich it's like
there is no it's just you keep moving
you just if you're one of these guys you
just you get in trouble you keep moving
you start winning again everyone goes
yeah but like they want so with with uh
Billy McFarland specifically after the
two documentaries one that was on
Netflix and the other that was on Hulu I
think they were so damning right people
got to learn about him as this
awful predatory business partner who
called in the military Genius of Jar Ru
to be his
operator like the guys that time uh that
time in New York was crazy too um that
by the way you and I our age group that
was us it was like the I think like the
2013 to 2016 Instagram was very
interesting because uh virality and and
new social media trends was popping and
my friend lived in New York at the time
and he I think he had one of those black
cards that Billy McFarland was making
and Ja R was promoting and like weird
[__] was happening in these clubs and
stuff and like weird Partnerships what a
brain trust that was really really
pulled in all of the high IQ players to
get jar Ru in to come and fix it and
then it's like almost if you do that if
you get someone who's a rapper in as
your business partner it's almost a
little bit like well you know we
couldn't have expected much it was jar
rule that you know he was the brains
behind the operation that tried to bring
it all to Market but yeah I I don't know
man like Billy McFarland separate to uh
Logan and and Jake specifically I think
Tate's kind of a bit of a different
animal but Logan and Jake have an
unbelievable resilience in terms of
their Public Image I don't know anybody
that's been able to ride waves in the
same way that those two guys have you
can throw anything that you want
anything that you want those guys and it
doesn't seem to stick and a little bit
of it is is kind of like were maybe
people have become desensitized to those
guys
being in the news for bad things it's ah
you know just like add it to the list
it's the the suicide forest and there's
the the crypto zoo and there's the this
thing like Prime doesn't have it's got
It's all potassium it's no sodium and
it's the you coconut concentrate not
coconut water and blah blah blah you
know it's just a a big list a big
laundry list of of things that have
occurred and people no longer really see
it with the same kind of gravity and the
final thing which is Destiny strategy
which works so well he's I've told you
about this before he calls it just keep
streaming which is like the Dory from
Finding Nemo just keep swimming just
keep swimming he says people only
remember your last three streams so on
the first one everyone's going to come
out and give you loads of [__] on the
second one they're going to give you
some [__] and then on the third one the
shit's kind of a little bit old and by
the fourth one everyone's G and I do
think that it's this sort of momentum
game that these guys are able to stay on
and regardless of what you think about
them regardless of whether you think
that Logan Paul is a good guy or a bad
guy or a media genius or an idiot that's
managed to position himself well his
ability to withstand media assault
whether it's from mainstream or below
the line whether it's legitimate or
manifested like artificially is ungodly
yeah it's the the nose blindness to
[__] up that I think that the world
has right [__] yeah yeah [__] yeah
that's such a good way to put it we're
just like the the room stinks like [__]
but we've been in here for two two hours
and at that point like it's it's you
know our our base
level yeah that's phenomenal I uh I
don't know about this this uh fire
Festival 2.0 it's like how is this guy
able to conduct a business is there
no business litigation thing that says
you know like you shoot someone and you
get out of jail and it's like yo you
don't get to Firearms anymore if you con
and trap people on an island with no
water and a couple of tents from
Hurricane Katrina guess what you don't
get to run festivals no more but maybe
he's got jar rule back in as the
operator I don't know this is uh this is
definitely a stipulation or a sanction
that a lot of white white collar
criminals face um when they go to jail
they're not allowed to trade anymore
they're not allowed to have they these
are literally written into um their
punishment
computer hackers aren't allowed access
to the internet or to be near a digital
device stuff like that precisely and I I
would love to know like the depth of
these because I think that's very
interesting I feel like your commenters
would you know some people in business
could CH chime in on it but I think
someone will know yeah someone will
definitely know but I think that yeah
there there has to be something like
that like he should not be able to do
this for sure there's no way but it's
like it's not even it's not even like oh
this is a tangential thing I've actually
pivoted and I'm going to do a calling it
fire fire two it's like f in fact the um
the website is like fire 2.com or
something oh sick you think it's
unbelievable and then he was he was
defrauding investors and doing all of
this other stuff so yeah I I don't know
man you you're right the world loves a
winner and this sort of trickle down
effect that you get of success you know
in the last year I've been around a lot
of like super successful people and they
have nothing short of a reality
Distortion field around them
like they they move and it's not largely
their fault like people just are so Keen
to not upset the person that they see as
being a Gateway between them and success
in the world that they're just they'll
it literally does move reality around
them and um yeah I I don't know we'll
see what happens with this Billy
mcfallen thing it's December 2024 uh
they've it's already sold out on the
first batch of tickets it are you
kidding it's already sold out but then
it was a it's really limited it looks
like there's only a th000 tickets in
total but the final stage of tickets top
out at 7 7 Grand each so it's not I
don't know it's like high high ticket
low
volume which is the opposite I think of
he just promised everything when he
previously and there was the 25 Grand
Villas and 100 Grand yachts and all
sorts of other [__] that was going on
all right next thing uh the
international powerlifting Federation
has changed its policy seemingly in
response to outrage generated by a male
dominating female competitions breaking
records along the way male competitor an
andr 40 recently defeated all female
competitors at the Canadian powerlifting
unions 2023 Western Canadian
championship by lifting a combined score
of
1,317 beating the second place finisher
by more than
450 you did a video on this a long time
ago or a good while ago you were really
out ahead of this
for the people that don't know what's
happening in powerlifting what's
happening with transgender uh categories
in in that spot so this was specific to
the uh CPC Canadian powerlifting com
commission or some some I forget what
the name of the actual Federation was
but it had to it was in Canada um and
that happened uh the the woman uh the
trans transwoman andrees I think was her
last name uh and so she wiped the floor
especially in the bench press um and
then uh there was the one of the head
coaches of the Canadian powerlifting
team when they went to ipf world so the
international powerlifting Federation
worlds he did a massive troll of this
rule which which stated at the time it
stated whatever you determine you are
self yes that is it and it was the at
the time it was pretty much the loosest
form of this although I think in
skateboarding they've been doing it you
know things that aren't officially
either Olympic sports or world champion
sanction sports with like wada and
things like that they've recognize self
ID for gender category determination so
if for a sport that's like has a pretty
decent World Federation this was a a
pretty crazy Rule and this guy went and
trolled it and he did aund like he for
him this bench press was pretty low like
160 kilos for a strong strong bencher is
really not hard like I I know guys that
can do sets of five with that and again
this is like so far above the average
human being it's ridiculous he goes up
and does 160 kilos and the next nearest
to him I think was like 105 so this is
the coach one of the coaches of the
Canadian powerlifting team female
powerlifting team a just team right okay
Canadian powerlifting team decided
bearded like 200 or more no like just a
man just a man who said I'm a woman now
decided to take this to the extreme with
this particular competition steps up
puts up a world what would probably be a
world
record uh yeah for sure by a distance in
terms of but it because it wasn't a
world it won't be classified as that but
had he have been at the Olympics or had
he have been somewhere else he would
have been that would have been a world
record that will never ever ever ever be
beaten correct yes and uh the craziest
thing was andrees was on the spotting
team for it she
was yeah so if he' failed the rep then
this person would have had to yeah the
woman who this was kind of pointing at
uh at the time it was in the same area
that's why why this happened and it's
interesting that this this rule came out
I didn't know that they had done it with
uh powerlifting because my sport is uh
Olympic weightlifting and that's what I
focus on they just recently came up with
a transgender category but I didn't know
that they did this but I had been
covering what this dude had done um and
it's interesting that they're making the
but they're probably following suit of
what was started by Fina which is the
national or the governing swimming
organization they were the first people
to produce a uh open
category um what's open open is the
category for Trans people who do not uh
transition before Tanner stage three
which is essentially just puberty like
it's essentially it's going to be uh 11
to 13 in females and let's say 12 to 14
in males or 11 to 14 in males so am I
right in saying that the current set of
rules now create a limit and the limit
is basically puberty for both boys and
girls if you go through that you are
unable to compete in the opposite gender
you could compete in your own gender
your biological sex or you could compete
in this open category but you couldn't
switch across to the other one however
if you did start on puberty blockers
before you hit puberty which is really
really rare to do it before gender
dysphoria seems to kick in once puberty
begins in any case and getting access to
it you know especially in the UK after
this Tav stock Clinic I had this lady on
the show who she was talking about how
this is really really being rolled back
in the UK which I think is a a very uh
positive development um it's going to be
very unlikely and you're going to have
to have one hell of a tyrannical parent
to go my daughter my son is going to be
a world champion female fale swimmer at
10 years old so we're going to like put
them on a course of puberty blockers so
that in 15 years time they can win a
gold medal that seems very unlikely yeah
so they they created this open category
the thing with that is though it is now
a self ident a self ID so you can have a
whirlwind of problems if someone decides
to self ID and Go destroy in that well
it depends how prestigious the open
category becomes it won't be it won't be
for sure and it won't be in the Olympics
either so that is the big thing with
when we look at uh swimming and uh
Olympic weightlifting and I'm assuming
that almost all Olympic sports are going
to have this domino effect um because
this is very new news for Olympic
weightlifting Olympic weightlifting just
not prevalent as powerlifting but this
just happened in in in my sport as well
uh and I feel like it's gonna just the
dominoes are going to fall and it's
going to be open category but the
problem is this open category will
likely not exist it's definitely not
going to exist in uh Paris who knows if
it'll ever exist and I think after Paris
is La uh but that's where really where
the limiting factor is like um I think
Fina responded to Leah Thomas yeah why
is it that you think that uh swimming
led the way because of Leah
Thomas it was it had to have been they
would never admit such a thing but that
whole Leo Thomas argument crossed every
bit of culture no matter you know if we
look at Olympic sports like we genuinely
don't care about it however there are
certain names especially like Michael
Phelps and and when the Olympics comes
on swimming is for sure one of the most
popular events so you know that Leah
Thomas thing comes in it's like we can
all kind of connect to swimming and then
uh you know that that was massive that
crossed everything that created a
massive culture war and I think fina's
response was directly from that and then
who was the one I want to say Riley Reid
but that's a pawn star who is the who's
the chick Riley gains
Riley uh track and field no she was the
blonde uh girl that kind of came out
being pro women she was like she was
like the Fox News to Leah Thomas's CNN
right there um I pretty sure it was
Riley GES there was a spokeswoman uh who
was Riley Gaines Riley gain I got it
right sorry for accusing you of being
Riley Reed there were a couples uh uh um
there were a couple of women who had
spoken out who were on previous Olympic
team
um but I will say this so Leah Thomas
for weightlifting it was a woman named
Laurel hubard and I've covered that
plenty of times on my channel it's like
I've literally been covering it for
forever but for those who who don't know
uh Laurel hubard she transitioned at 33
years old and was a junior uh
weightlifting champion at in New Zealand
and mind you the numbers that when it
was he he
uh he was lifting were not competitive
on the international scale uh in fact
I've actually lifted more than both of
uh his previous Junior uh pick whichever
identification you want you've lifted
more than them right uh but that but
that that's not to say that I'm a good
lifter it's just to say that like it's
good but it's not internationally good
not even remotely close uh the
transition happens and uh she wins the
Commonwealth
Games she didn't didn't she bow
Commonwealth championships didn't she
bow out of something was it Tokyo that
she so she got injured sna [__] she
snapped her [__] in uh I think it was
the World Championships where we had an
American woman in the same category and
I know her coach and I know her and if
she had medled and taken away a medal
from her they would have freaked out
these are southern people from Texas
it's where they train they would have
freaked out um yeah so that that Laurel
hubard the response is now uh you know
uh the iwf which is the international
weightlifting Federation they placed the
open category then we have the whole
andrees and I think the guy's name is
AVI silverberg or something like that AI
something and that whole drama created a
bunch of you know culture War drama then
they responded to that it's almost as if
every one of these uh organizations
they're all responses to these big
culture War snaps so it does work it
does work but it depends it depends on
what you mean by it does work is it the
response that's working or is it the
fact that you need a Leah Thomas a
laurel hubard and Andre person to
spearhead uh push back like they they
they cause a problem and then people
respond to that but it definitely seems
like the three Sports there may be more
sports that this is happened in I
haven't seen it the three sports that
have done it and been most forthcoming
with it are the ones that have had the
most coverage about trans athletes I
think track and field is next for sure
so because we had uh there was an
interex uh 800 meter Sprinter who or 800
meter Runner Sor it's mid distance uh
who's like the fastest woman of all time
like in that I forget forget the name it
was is you know the open category is the
open category M to f open and F to M
open or is it just one block of
both I'm not sure I'm leaning
towards I'm I'm leaning towards just one
block of both because if it's if it's a
single block then there's unfairness the
F to M that that every single one of
those athletes isn't part of this right
it's another it's another sport that's
dominated by biological men it it
wouldn't make sense to to just have it
as one but then again you have two okay
well now there's
how many competitors are there does it
keep just going and going yeah yeah and
then it's the FTM who have got gluten
intolerance and athletes foot then it's
the FTM who've got gluten- intolerance
athletes foot and and like didn't like
to eat peas as a kid and you just keep
on rolling down from there right I the
that is the one of the biggest arguments
uh of people who are in support of
self-identification is that sport is
filled with disadvantages and advantages
so someone can be born with more
testosterone than someone else so is
that an advantage that we need to now
hinder because testosterone works on a
spectrum you know you could say this
with so many different things humans are
born differently but that's why we have
sport to see who is different yeah to
see who is different but we need to have
some sort of classification male female
and now open yeah very interesting I'm
waiting
for the it'll happen at some point and
it'll get laughed out of the room but
there is a there will be a very extreme
body positivity sort of victimhood
progressive narrative that comes to try
and take out success in sports it's like
so why is it that the thinnest people
are the ones that get to do gymnastics
like who is it that actually says that
these standards of being able to do a
backflip are the best in gymnastics who
actually says that Grace or the quickest
one because I noticed that when I look
at the line of the 100 meters finals
that's not a very diverse set of bodies
that we've got up there you know I I do
think that you're going to see like some
insane ridiculous person trying to push
this narrative uh but lizo unfortunately
uh is not doing her part for the body
positive Community CU you see this story
about her making
dancers eat bananas out of the vaginas
of strippers and in Amsterdam and then
body shaming them all and doing all the
rest of it yeah you know I it's a I
think Tim Dylan and Joe Rogan talked
about this and Tim had a really good
point it was
like lizo kind of went on and hired
people to be her dancers
that aren't professional dancers you
know like they they're they're good you
know and then they're plus-sized and the
point was I want to prove that you know
these people can be in Show business as
well and what happened was there was a a
line of problems that followed up on it
and then I think someone tried to record
her uh like being
abusive and then she threatened to like
lock the doors and figure out who it was
but yeah I I gotta be honest with you
man I can't I couldn't care less about
lizo and the and and the things that she
does to be fair yeah well if you think
that that woman was ever being genuinely
like Pro body positivity I don't think
that you're a particularly good judge of
of people like Ellen De generous I know
that there was all of this news that
came out about her and how mean she was
and stuff like that she didn't ever seem
like anyone to me that wasn't just a
performative mouthpiece for what she
thought would make her likable and or
make make her money make her money yeah
which included being being likable all
right next thing that I want to talk to
you about do you think that watching
porn constitutes
cheating this is a good
one um let me give you some more context
and you can ponder on that question
along with everybody El is there a study
uh a woman explains why she made her
husband look away when Florence Pew
appeared in Oppenheimer apparently there
is a runy sex scene throughout
Oppenheimer and this lady West Virginia
Tik tocker Jordan Kerr has revealed that
there's one scene her husband didn't
watch while they were enjoying the new
movie at the cinemas as he had to close
his eyes and rest his head on her
shoulder this is all because she said
she suffered betrayal trauma after
discovering that he watched porn one of
her female followers had asked if she
had any advice for how her and her
husband could watch Oppenheimer whilst
being fully afraid of the Florence Pew
scene everyone's talking about and she
said that she researched aggressively
every single movie that they're going to
watch before they watch it and
especially this one and when the movie
came up he had to place his head on his
on her shoulder with his eyes closed and
then she got to tell him when that scene
had finished uh I went through betrayal
trauma 10 months ago after 9 years of
marriage 10 years of being a completely
monogamous relationship she said I was
fully under the belief that he didn't
look at other women he didn't
self-pleasure at other women porn was
the furthest thing from my mind I never
would have thought or believed that he
was using porn but he was and I found
out about it on September 17th 2022 that
was the hardest day of my life it was
the hardest following weeks and
following months of my life betrayal
trauma has changed me as a person inside
and out it put me through a lot of
stress it put me through a lot of pain
it put me through sickness it put me
through depression gave me a lot of
stress and a lot of anxiety I've come a
long way in healing I'm still with my
husband and so happy and thankful I'm
proud to say that he's been sober for 10
months he's been doing all the steps all
the work everything necessary to not
only change and stay sober reach
long-term recovery but also assure me
that he is creating a self safe space he
is becoming a trustworthy person and he
is showing me the signs that I need by
his actions his behaviors and his
patterns that he is going in the right
direction
uh yeah so that the context is important
with that situation for sure like if
you're having problems uh then yeah uh
both Partners should stay away from
self-pleasuring and and porn and like
look to each other for that I think
that's got to be a pretty intuitive
response um if the porn is literally
taking away from your sex life between
you and your partner then yes it's
absolutely a problem and it and it
hasn't and there's been some there was
like a massive meta analys meta analysis
on this do you know which one I'm
talking about it talks about porn use
and um the relationship to either failed
relationships or failed marriages and it
was a huge huge can you remember what
the outcome was it I mean it was just
the more porn the less likelihood of the
longevity of your uh but but the thing
is the porn could be a result of
problems and then it it doesn't fix it
which direction is the correlation Arrow
going here do people that are in bad
relationships watch porn or does porn
cause you to have a bad relationship
right and maybe both are true MH uh but
I I I think you know um it's just all
communication like I went with my
partner to see Oppenheimer she didn't
[__] even think twice about the
Florence Pew scene we she's like oh
Florence Pew great actress cool I'm like
yeah cool nice tits he's like yeah you
pass the popcorn yeah with a whole that
movie was [__] amazing dude how how
is that the the part where you're
stressing man that was the most
important that was the most important
part so what I've got in my head there's
another article here about the same
thing from distractify.com
uh after finding out that her husband
had an addiction one woman began
documenting her recovery journey and
helping other women in her spot on Tik
Tok finding out your partner has a drug
addiction or drinking problem is one
thing but finding out they are addicted
to watching sex sexually explicit
content of other women is a whole
different ballpark how so well it's an
ADD ition that involves betrayal the
partner with the addiction chose to
experience and lust over other bodies
rather than their Partners when one
woman learned her husband had that type
of an addiction she starts documenting
on Tik Tok so I'm wondering how many men
have been rumbled by a partner who
evidently doesn't feel particularly
comfortable with being sexually open
sociosexual in evolutionary psychology
speak I bet that she's very low I think
that she's probably got some she said it
drove her into anxiety and depression
which probably suggests that she maybe
was predisposed to that maybe got some
self-esteem issues and stuff like that
so she's a perfect cocktail for this to
trigger something which is really really
bad in her I wonder how many men have
been caught by that and played the same
card that every celebrity for the rest
of time when he's been caught cheating
has played it's it's my addiction it's
my pathology they've pathologized like
using porn once every couple of nights
or once every week right in an attempt
to try and so I would say I would give
it at least a 50% chance probably more
probably like a 90% chance that this guy
doesn't have an addiction to porn that
this is his way of making his partner
calm down with the thing was it stated
in in the thing that he was addicted
it's said on it's said on both that he
was addicted but I'm going to guess that
that's self ID right but porn addiction
is a real thing and it's really uh it's
I don't dis I don't disagree but I think
porn addiction genuine genuine porn
addiction is relatively rare it's it's
really really rare actually especially
in a relationship to be addicted to porn
is is wild and to go to recovery groups
and stuff but anyway the thing that's
interesting here is and obviously like
the the point to get around
to
is is it reasonable for a partner to
have a problem with their partner
watching porn and if it is is it
unreasonable for you to uh pleasure
yourself on your own without porn and if
it is should you have some sort of
Minority Report mind reporting thing
that says the only person that you could
fantasize about whilst on your own even
if it wasn't with porn in front of you
is your partner and what do you do if a
thought Creeps in about that one girl
that one hot girl from high school or
that chick that trains in the gym or
whatever how scrutinized should your
fantasies be to the point where you feel
I've betrayed my partner you know during
last night's fap I actually thought
about Katie from 2007 and that's it I
guess I've cheated on her now darling
I'm going to have to take myself to
rehab the this what helps me kind of
parse through this is thinking about the
timeline because um you know porn at
this
level was not available up until like
what
2000 99 maybe and then I'd say maybe in
like
nineish is when it became okay now you
can get any porn you want to stream uh
so that's an important factor right
because like what would somebody in the
70s how would this how how were people
thinking about this in the 70s well if
they didn't have porn access to porn
they were looking at nudie mags all the
time then I guess that would be a
problem but if they're not and they're
masturbating well then they're using
their mind to think about something else
um I think what that comes down to is
like the difference between fantasy in
reality and like a lot
of this is just my understanding of it
but a lot of women specifically like
fantasy to them is so separate to their
reality like uh if you if you think
about how well all of these fantasy
novels like romance novels do um if we
think about how incredible uh 50 Shades
of Gray did like I don't know the
numbers on that but it was a mass thing
it was a cultural phenomenon that's a
movie
where I would say like the only way a
woman can enjoy that is to think about
that scenario and is it with their
partner so the the the the interesting
thing here is men State around about an
average of four uh sexual partners per
fantasy so if you're having a sexual
fantasy you will tend to cycle through
in one session about four because the
male desire for sexual variety is
significantly higher women will tend to
be one which is why in any romance I
mean there's some probably some novels
out there that are a bit different
almost all romance novels have a single
protagonist right the woman
isn't bouncing from bed to bed between
different guys because that doesn't
fulfill the fantasy that on average most
women have which is a single usually
very high value usually very high status
kind of rough around the edges man that
she civilizes she domesticates him
because of his desire for her that is
the typical sort of narrative that you
see in this if men had romance novels
each chapter would be a different gang
bang with a group of different women
right like that's the way it would work
so it it's definitely using if if you
were to say and there may be people out
there that do if you were to say that
even the thought of fantasizing about a
different person to your partner is
constitutes
cheating that is a very female Centric
frame to place around this and that's
biological predisposition very robust
male desire for sexual variety is higher
number of fantasies number of Partners
in any one given fantasy for men is way
higher than it is for women now maybe
you can say if you were sufficiently
faithful and this was genuine Chastity
you would be able to use your love for
your partner and your desire for them
and you could T down all of these other
things and this shows that you're not
actually as as whatever is is
but if I was to take as balanced of a
view as I can I think that that's
firstly unrealistic and secondly a
little bit unfair on men that's not for
me to say that men should be going out
of their way to like reminisce or
fantasize about their cooworker at work
when they've got a wife who's pregnant
and two kids at home but we just need to
be realistic here like you don't get to
control every single thing that goes
through your mind and unless you're
going to peer into someone's mind and
that what it thought crime am I allowed
to think things anymore we get into very
dangerous territory well so I I don't
know who said this but it's this idea of
uh thinking things is not always the
problem thinking bad things is not the
problem it's the action of making those
things that you think physical and that
can be so if you're in a search bar on
porn you're searching for that thing
you're thinking of okay well now you are
making that thought real and it is a
potentially you know that that can creep
into your partner's mind as as being
something problematic uh even further
than that if you're thinking of another
woman
uh maybe that's bad maybe that's not but
if you message that woman you have now
and and or if you say what you're
thinking about that woman to another man
Even um that's where it's like you
become what you say and what you create
in the world much more than what you
think yeah we're just going to think
think think think think new thing comes
in new thing comes in and then you know
so I think in a certain extent I think
women can be correct in this you know
what would be the line then like don't
write out what you want to see because
then you
know I guess I guess it depends I guess
it depends on exactly how sensitive that
particular woman is to what's going on I
would be interested to know whether men
would have a problem with their
partner uh watching por their female
partner watching porn I would almost be
certain at guessing that if it was
lesbian porn which a massive proportion
of women do watch that they probably
wouldn't care uh it's the same as the
like oneid one-sided open relationship
that we're seeing in Austin a lot which
is well we bring additional people into
our marriage or our relationship but
it's always a woman and fundamentally
the guy just isn't quite as threatened
but yeah I'd be interested to know what
people think uh I I don't know in the
comments let us know if you think that
watching porn when you're with a partner
is cheating is
fantasizing about an imaginary woman
cheating is fantasizing about like what
if you just enhance your partner a
little bit what if you make them a bit
more tanned or you put them in a blonde
wig or like you imagine that they've got
a different job like it's just there's a
line and at some point you have to say
well that's it that's but I I would say
on average that that lady there could
probably do with doing a little bit of
resilience work like if if you are
getting triggered by your partner
watching and she's recently come out of
this thing that she was evidently
predisposed to and she's like trauma
response or whatever it is and all the
rest of the
stuff I would say on average that that
person is in for a hard life if they are
permanently being vigilant to okay so we
walk past Victoria Secrets does he have
to close his eyes and walk into a
lampost when it's Victoria Secrets there
but what about if they change it for
body positive models does that make it
different that sounds very big phobic or
fat phobic or whatever it is so I don't
know anyway next thing Bradley Cooper
the Leonard Leonard Bernstein family
defendant actor over the Maestro nose
row so Leonard Bernstein is in a movie
or he is being played by Bradley Cooper
in a movie and uh it attracted some
criticism over the size of Cooper's nose
which some social media users said
played up to offensive Jewish
stereotypes Bernstein's family said they
were perfectly fine with Cooper using
makeup to amplify his appearance there
has also been criticism that a Jewish
actor was not cast to play the Westside
Story composer breaks our hearts to see
any misrepresentation or
misunderstandings of Cooper's efforts
wrote Jamie Alexander and Nina Bernstein
in a statement posted online now you'll
remember recently the uh Snow White and
the Seven Dwarves movie uh started sort
of ramping up a little bit of movement
didn't cast dwarves for the dwarfs
didn't cast little people and a lot of
dwarf actors had a problem with that and
Hollywood came out and said you know
this it's it's Antiquated they're like
figurative dwarfs it's a fairy tale and
yet when it suits them no one that isn't
gay can play a gay actor no one that
isn't whatever can play whatever actor
uh I I think that there's a a massive
asymmetry going on with the selection
effect here Bradley Cooper I don't know
his politics but he just looks like
someone that would probably be a bit
right-wing and I think that that
probably doesn't play into it very very
well so the the dwarves thing is
interesting because um froo bagin and
you know uh was played by Elijah Wood uh
and they're halflings they're literally
four feet tall maybe even smaller than
that and I think the reality was like
Hobbits have the same dimensions as
people and I think dwarves uh don't
that's part of their like condition so
it's like okay well are we is it a
height thing that we're looking for is
it you know it's a it is a very weird
thing man because on the other side of
that if you had
people playing a an African-American
person or a black person and they just
wore
blackface that's that's the worst of it
right it's GNA go badly but if you to do
the if you do to do the reverse you know
we've got period dramas like uh
Bridgeton uh and other U movies to do
with Vikings uh series to do with the
Middle Ages and regularly somebody of an
ethnic minority that isn't from that era
in that region will be injected into it
in an attempt to increase diversity
so I I don't know I I think that
everybody's getting very very sensitive
about characters playing the characters
and I do understand that for instance
with the dwarf thing I don't imagine
that there's that many roles for dwarfs
in Hollywood so maybe it's a good idea
to actually limit those roles to the
people for whom there is a very limited
amount of work but then on the flip side
of that if you say okay and if you want
to cast somebody who is suffering with
Parkinson's to play a Parkinson's
patient like that's going to go very
badly you're not going to have a
particularly good movie because you're
not selecting the best person so this is
why it's interesting it's interesting
because you want to have the best person
for the role but you also there is a
degree of like well you know if this
role is for a very specific sort of
person and they get pushed to one side
that also kind of doesn't feel fat and I
think this tension is is what makes it
interesting this is definitely
unprecedented right because now
Hollywood knows that they can you know
uh the mob can [__] about Prosthetics
now uh and and how they can you know
play up certain
stereotypes uh but I'm looking right now
at an image and it's Leonard Bernstein
next to Bradley Cooper's Leonard
Bernstein um there's obviously
Prosthetics but there's prosthetic ears
looks like his cheeks a little bit
uh in the
nose but I wonder if they just didn't do
that if it would have made a difference
I don't know because part of it's like
you want to look like the guy because if
people know who Leonard Bernstein is and
they they recognize his face well then
it's going to be really important that
the person playing him looks like him
yeah so you should have got a berian
lookalike when Will Smith played
Muhammad Ali he had his ears pinned back
because Will Smith's ears stick out way
more than Muhammad Ali's do and yeah
know that yeah yeah he had his ears
pinned back for the movie um here's
something else I just saw this before I
was coming on you've been following this
vivec ramas Swani guy do you know who
that is Republican candidate and he
is doing a lot of kind of viral talking
head moments whether it's on in on
Street interviews or uh to the press and
he's a really really slick talker say
what you want about politics and his
positions on X Y and Zed but he's an
unbelievably slick talker it's very it
is very very very impressive and I think
he's sort of catching up in the polls
and doing all the rest of
it and then I went on his Twitter and he
is doing because he's young I think he's
37 or 38 so he been by far the youngest
president ever maybe he's like maybe
he's in his 40s or something but he's
like around about that age and his
debate prep he always uploads videos of
him doing debate prep and it's this
video of him absolutely hammering forand
Strokes forand Baseline Strokes with his
top off in the sunshine and the guy is
in good condition and I'm like what what
world is this and there's another one
he's like three hours of debate prep
today or whatever and then there's
another one of him with his top off
doing burpees with his partner really
really interesting that' be that's a big
change from Old Grandpa Joe yeah you
know Trump the guy that the guy that
said that you have a a particular number
of heartbeats and if you train if you
exercise it uses up your heartbeats more
quickly that is that what Trump said I'm
pretty sure he said that or maybe maybe
it's a lie that I heard I don't know
that's
incredible but the dude's just hammering
thunderous forehands on the Baseline
yeah that's so sick it's impressive do
you see that uh Trump has bowed out of
the
Republican uh initial debate whatever
the first like GOP debate is and he's
going to live stream with Tucker Carlson
on Twitter Instead at the same time wow
okay so so uh and that's so well
actually is what it's called now um oh
man that's going to
be how many views I mean doesn't Twitter
get the most views of anything right now
it does but it's because the criteria
for getting a view on it is the lowest
it's you know it's a half second scroll
past and when you've got autoplay uh on
a platform it counts pretty much anyone
going past it as a view which I I I
don't think is fair that being said you
can get into the analytics on the back
end and see 3 second views 30 second
views 60c views I think calculate all
watch time would be be cool I would love
to see that I would love to see the
comparison between the two yeah yeah
hilarious all right next thing uh San
franciscans are having sex in Robo taxis
and nobody is talking about it have you
ever thought about getting down and
dirty in a robo taxi all the time what
want to light up a Sig or a joint on the
drive home from the club you're not
alone as autonomous vehicles have become
increasingly popular in San Francisco
some Riders are wondering just how far
they can push the vehicle limits
especially with no front seat driver or
chaperon to discourage them from
questionable behavior from some that's a
welcome invitation to test invitation to
test the auto autonomous vehicles limits
Megan a woman in her 20s took her first
Robo taxi on a recent late night
Excursion it's also her first time
having sex in a driverless vehicle just
going to pause there what do you mean it
was also her first time having sex in a
driverless vehicle like that's a rare
thing yeah like that's not every got be
everyone's first man yeah right okay so
uh the standard is not providing exact
dates of the Riders debauchery to
protect their privacy but has verified
the rides took place through
documentation okay so I'm glad that
they've been fact checked on whether or
not this happened we got in and just got
straight to it making out said Megan who
got into the cruise wearing nothing but
a robe one thing led to another and he
made sure I was taken care of if you
will I was like I have no underwear on
and I'm ready to go in this kimono and I
was using his slippers that were five
sizes too big this sounds awful
you have you ever tried to have sex in a
car that's probably of the size size
that this autonomous vehicle is uh no
right I lost my virginity in a VW Lop
which
is increased the difficulty that's such
I'm sorry but that is get more of a UK
car to have hey be more be more British
yeah be more British you can't there's
no
way yeah let me tell you man like if you
don't know what you're doing not knowing
what you're doing in a car
is way harder uh so I've seen those
autonomous vehicles driving around yep
uh in
Austin uh so every time I see one I have
to take a picture of it going by it's
it's crazy to me still it's gonna be
crazy somebody's in case somebody's
getting butt [__] in the back seat
yeah well you know that would be uh Buck
[__] in the backseat of a robo taxi
that's going to be my romance novel um
speaking of romance novels that could be
the sequel to uh [__] down in Dallas
but [__] in a robo taxi yes and so I
think the the easiest solution to this
problem is you just say it's a public
place right even though it's private
transport but like you have to have
public rules then
because you you wouldn't be you're not
able to just because you can't see any
driver and the place is empty it's um
you know illegal to have sex in a Subway
or or in in you know any sort of tram or
something like that so this is weird too
because there's cameras on the inside of
all of those things you know so I don't
know who gets it yeah there's the
cameras everywhere on those things they
have to be because someone could just
come in and [__] up the whole entire
thing and no one would know it's like a
bird scooter at that point just a really
expensive bird scooter do you reckon
anyone's ever had sex on a bird
scooter while it's moving yeah no well
our our friend fully planted off that
and it took like 6 weeks to recover uh I
know someone who uh had to have
basically
reconstructive teeth like
their severed [__] nerves and [__] in
their teeth cut they fell off a bird
scooter man how awful me and you me and
you have done stupid things on birds
driving a thing is we're too athletic
that's the thing right you are tempting
fate there the next time that we're you
can't teach this right yeah you can't
this grace is is Unstoppable but yeah I
don't know the robot taxi thing I would
be very interested to see if this
becomes a kink and if you start to see
oh for sure for sure will be yeah like
grinder but for
cars whoa driver driver yeah
drvr yep well there's a business
opportunity let's do it invest now
6969 a month what else you been doing
tell me about your trip to Japan and
what was it like being that oh man Japan
was incredible
um the the best way to describe Japan is
one moment that I had and it was it
was we all stopped when we saw it and
we're like okay wow this is Tokyo at
least Tokyo we didn't venture outside of
it but this is when we realized like wow
this is what Japan is about This Woman's
walking her dog and the dog lifts the
leg up to take a piss on like this post
it's kind of like this barricade
blocking this this uh uh Causeway where
it's only walking and she takes out her
water bottle that isn't it's a it's a
literal water bottle that like it's like
a Dan basically with a spray top on it
and she sprays down where the dog
pissed I have never seen anything like
that there is no litter or Garbage
anywhere there are hardly any bins for
throwing things away um the engineering
of something as simple as an elevator
everywhere I went was ridiculous so it's
like you get in the elevator you press
where you're going and then you're
moving and you're like wait a minute did
we start moving and then and then the
door opens it's like did how did we stop
moving you can't feel it that's how good
the engineering is it's like the process
of being an engineer for an elevator
must be so robust the the
process right I got a cup of coffee
at the place next to our Airbnb got into
my elevator that felt like a [__]
spaceship it was like got down opened it
up took a left went right into to get my
coffee this guy made the greatest latte
and I I vlogged about it and people were
freaking out made the greatest latte
ever he measured out the ice CU he like
literally put the cup on a scale he had
different spoons so that spoons wouldn't
touch different of his ground up
beans this process and he was going
pretty fast it took like two three four
minutes to make but I filmed the whole
thing and it was the greatest latte I've
ever had and he didn't even think about
it he just handed it to me he goes there
you go and like looked away I'm like bro
if I was handing this to someone I'd be
like yeah [__] you're gonna like this
thing you know because I'm an American
I'm gonna be like yeah I just killed
that thing right there you got to tell
me how good it is how good I did that's
just their culture is just
find things that are interesting or or
good and just be the [__] best at it
and don't talk about it you know that
the uh the world champion Barista the
current title holder at least the title
holder in 2021 for a couple of years was
Japanese so I think that they have an
unbelievably strong coffee culture and
whiskey culture too oh yo do you
remember that whiskey that we had when
we went for sushi at uh I love this
story because we went we got the best
some of the best Sushi I've ever had um
and I did go to Japan I probably had
better Sushi there but the we're not
drinking at this it's like a Tuesday we
didn't want to drink so they come by
after it and they're like hey does
anyone want whiskey and we're like no no
no no he comes
back our our waiter comes back and he
he's like so this whiskey was has been
ranked number one in the world for the
past 15 years we had to put our names in
two years ago to get a bottle of it and
then me and you look at it we're like
well now that you mention it I'm going
to say no yeah yeah of course I'm going
to have some whiskey now it was
literally the best whiskey we could have
had uh so yeah yeah there's a weight
list they only issue 50 bottles of this
around the world each year it goes to
VIPs who know the the batch small
batches all that [__] uh yeah and then
talk to me about because I've never been
to either talk to me about Japan and
Korea what was the movement between the
two like yeah so the the flight to Korea
I think it's like an hour and 40-minute
flight super easy Soul airport which or
inin airport is
amazing I think that I liked the Korean
food and Korean culture more than I
expected to is definitely someplace
where I want to go back for sure uh the
people and and the traditional culture
it is a pretty conservative culture
there like you not really allowed to be
gay there I don't think like it's it's
not quite turkey level there's OB it's
like
yeah it's like a little bit too much
here guys but I um the the food was like
incredible it was incredible it probably
my favorite food I've ever ever had in
any like period it was did they do
Korean bobq out there or is it I guess
it's just barbecue out there yeah and
but it's like what they're Korean
barbecue for us is like this big event
thing but for them it's like they're
just cooking the food for you and like
walking away it's like like they'll just
put the steak on the grill and cook it
flip it and then they'll cut it for you
and then they'll put it off to the side
and they'll just keep adding more to it
so you just pick and grab when you're
when you want something it's that simple
like um and yeah we had that all the
time this one guy took us out he we were
drinking with them their drinking
culture is absolutely
insane uh I it's
like it's definitely alcoholic like
style of drinking we show up it's
immediately
five straight glasses of beer mixed with
Soju like back to back to back to back
to back uh and then we went out from
there but that it was it was just
incredible soul is an in is a great City
definitely an underrated City and Korea
is going through this massive explosion
at the same time their birth rate is the
worst of any of the modern world correct
yeah there's going to be 96% fewer
Koreans in 100 years than there will be
now holy [__] [__] yeah and Japan that's
not that far did you see a single
pregnant person in Japan or in
Korea I saw some kids in in
Japan I saw some kids in Tokyo I saw a
child and there was like a kindergarten
that I walked by bunch of cute little
kids just running around yeah but Korea
no yeah I don't even think I saw a
teenager in Korea it's not good Korea's
not career's not good on that on that
front really really really not good yeah
that was it that was my experience we
used to have um at one of the big club
nights that we used to run it was uh
Asian sock I think and uh
this couple of uh guys ran it and they
were able to move 400 people right and
that meant that they were like super
super super high value to us because 400
people in a nightclub is a nightclub
right and then if you've already got a
busy nightclub that's that's just pure
profit so we would sort of grief the
groups of these guys and try and keep in
in with them as much as possible and
they would always arrive 130 in the
morning like super super late and order
just joab Bombs all that they wanted was
Jaga bombs but I'm sure you'll know this
from Fitness Asian people lack a a high
proportion of Asian people lack a
particular enzyme that allows them to
break down alcohol and they got asian
flush and it's like a mild allergic
reaction to having alcohol on the more
severe end it can actually cause people
to feel like digestive discomfort they
can throw up and there's like the
Baseline wanting to throw up of just
having aab bomb or five Jager Bombs like
just a normal person who can digest this
stuff will have that and then you roll
on Top This lack of an enzyme and the
Asian flour and all this other stuff and
dude it was like every single time that
they were coming in there was a
balancing act that me and my business
partner had to make which was 300 people
400 people
fantastic lots of sick like lots and
lots of sick puking yeah upstairs in the
R&B room so there was always this
balancing act that we had to make but it
it it's really fascinating I'd love to
find out from an Asian person why
alcohol is it's such an aggressive type
of drinking it's oh yeah binge drinking
there is no chill no I'm I'm I've never
uh done a dinner like this I don't think
I ever will again like it's it's almost
so just picture this we sit down we're
like getting excited they're cooking the
meat we have uh bunch of big bottles of
beer and Soju which is like kind of like
watered down it tastes like water down
vodka but it's a rice liquor and it's
Korean um and he'll pour it in a glass
that's like maybe eight ounces maybe
yeah like a cup of coffee size glass and
then he'll put in at least a shot of
Soju in each one of them uh and he'll
hand it to you and it's so it's 8 ounces
it's you know and and he will you cheers
uh and then there's a bunch of
interesting stuff you point your glass
away from the Elder like the bottom of
your glass you point away from your
Elder also when you're receiving a drink
you have to grab it with your right hand
you should usually just drink with your
right hand uh and then you should
probably hold on to your arm or like
basically your wrist or your arm or your
chest when when someone's giving you a
drink when they're like your did you ask
why it's just out of respect yeah why is
that
respect it looks it looks pretty
respectful actually it's just it's like
bowing almost if it's like a very human
movement like I'm really happy to accept
this from you so he did we did that you
drink all eight ounces boom puts it down
more stuff goes on it's like oh [__] you
filled it again cheers it's as soon as
he fills it he hands it to you cheers
again and again and again then we eat a
little bit oh I forgot we haven't been
drinking again again it's chugging
[__] 8 ounce drinks uh the the thing
was though I am a 240
pound you know Anglo Saxon descent yeah
but I don't I don't really drink that
often when I do I'll drink pretty hard
and I'll party pretty hard but I'm not
an experienced Drinker by any stretch uh
but he was getting hammered we were all
getting hammered but he he kind of bowed
out a little bit earlier than I expected
you know for people who's part of their
B their culture is binge drinking which
is super interesting and I that's
interesting why you brought up the the
like as flush thing CU I think that
played a part in it for sure you can
take my old business partner used to
take um a tablet that I think helped to
fix the particular enzyme interesting
problem that they that he had but yeah
man I don't know I I wonder what people
from Korea and Japan think when they
come to the UK like look at me coming
from one of the larest most binge
drinking cultures on the planet going
these Asian people drinking a lot like
yeah no Chris I'm I'm sorry if dude I
did a seminar this is also part of my
trip I did a seminar in in Sunderland
but I was staying in Newcastle yeah
literally on that street that you used
to work on yeah for the people for the
people who know Newcastle he was staying
just behind AA just down the hill from
lello it was I have never seen nightlife
like that it was the loudest and dude it
was people of all ages there were like
40-year-old
getting oh my God they were getting
shitfaced and
screaming uh it was nuts that was binge
drinking like I have never really seen
it's it's almost treated like a
competitive sport for sure for sure yes
I don't see that like you do not see
that in Austin you don't no no well I
guess I don't know we we go we go on
Sixth Street sometimes like if we if
we're going to see comedy and stuff and
sometimes there's but even there it's
not that aggressive man it's not yeah I
suppose you are right if you've got some
bachelorette party in from Nashville
wearing pter fun you know like I feel
like the people in Newcastle are like oh
[__] it's Friday let's black out like
let's I mean did you ever used to have
that cuz I remember when oh we did we
did now that I say that those words have
literally come out out of my mouth when
I was younger so yeah it's Friday let's
let's [__] ourselves up yeah there was
this thing and this was one of the big
uh changes that I had when I did sub
I went
from having a Friday afternoon itch
which was this compulsion this desire to
party like I just wanted to to go out
and get [__] up and even if it wasn't
get [__] up I just wanted to go out
like I'd got to the end of the week and
I'd conditioned myself into okay it's a
Friday I've worked hard this week
therefore it's time to go out and party
and even if you take it moderately
a moderate session in the UK is still
going to be eight drinks right plus
probably and yeah it was every single
week you get to Friday afternoon and
there's this it's like when you know
that you want a
coffee but for a beer yeah the dude all
I can say is there's certain like the
music industry which I've tapped into a
bit in Austin it's like the excitement
of Friday happens every night that's
when it gets really scary like you get
you wouldn't expect it but like your
boys have a show at you know somewhere
on Sixth Street or somewhere on West 6th
Street or rainy or whatever and you end
up showing up and they're killing and
it's fun and everyone's dancing and then
they their set ends and they want a
party now because they everyone's happy
it's like fight up wait it's a [__]
Tuesday night you know and you guys are
going to do this on Thursday and you
know Friday Saturday Sunday it's crazy
when stuff like that happens the the
entertainment business is for sure a
dangerous one I've also been in the
comedian like I've been tapped into the
comedy you know we were we were at the
club we were sitting in the green room
with all those comedians they're all
drinking smoking the whole time so yeah
I think I think that
cultural uh excitement just always being
excited is really tough the highs are
high man but the lows are very low yeah
I guess I was talking to
Nick mutual friend with the mustache and
uh I was saying to him about how because
he doesn't drink when he plays he DJs it
must be so hard to do something that's
adrenaline fueled and that's your
passion and you know you've just left a
crowd at 2: in the morning with them in
this unbelievably hyped State and you've
been thinking and you've been focusing
you've been doing all this stuff and now
it's time to get into a quiet car and go
home and your bird's been asleep for 4
and a half hours and you need to sneak
in and you just lie there and stare at
the ceiling
and you just hear this loud noise yeah
it's it's really difficult dude like the
the The Nightlife industry is and all
sorts of entertainment that happen late
at night is [__] unforgiving uh like
I was messing and relatively thankless
too I think because it is transient in
in a way where like the people so if
you're in a bachelor party or
bachelorette party you go in party and
have the time of your life at these bars
but then you wake up in reality hits and
you don't even want anything to do with
those people those
things they are hurt that is super super
interesting so um especially if you're
not this is the difference I think
largely between being a producer and
being a DJ or by being a uh a musician
who plays gigs and a musician that makes
music um because if you're just there to
be a soundtrack to the party there's an
upper bound on how existentially
connected people are going to feel to
you right they're not like you're not
changing their life you might give them
a really great event or whatever and you
might even get famous off the back of it
but it's totally different to being
someone who produces music that they
listen to on the way to the gym or after
they've had a breakup or that helps them
to understand that they were you know
that they were alone as a child I cannot
I cannot recommend this documentary
enough it is the avichi
documentary um because that is what
killed him I ultimately I believe that's
what killed the man was uh there there
was a brilliant scene where he's arguing
with his manager and he goes hey man I'm
I'm not doing Vegas I'm not doing the
residency in Vegas and he's like I kind
of signed you up for it and he's like I
don't [__] care I'm not [__] doing
it I'm quitting I'm not gonna DJ anymore
I am not doing Vegas smash
cut [__] Vegas doing it oh and they
they had a show counter on it it was
like first it was like first 20 shows
he's [__] loving it and it gets up to
like 570 shows uh in like less I mean it
was literally maybe a day off flying
from he would tour and then he would
have his residency that he would fly
back to so the off days he was doing a
residency yeah uh and that was it right
there um and this day and age in music
you you this is content now it's
algorithm based so you can get big and
famous from the comfort of your own home
you produce content and you can get it
out through social media it's not about
radio plays it's not about because aichi
came up through blogs I don't know or
where blogs were like uh I don't know if
you remember any of those those blogs
that we used to get music off of um but
they would promote these these DJs and
that's how they got big then they gig
like crazy but now there's Spotify is
algorithmic you have a good enough song
that goes well on Tik Tok it becomes
algorithmic it'll bounce around you can
stay home and it sucks that a guy like
that missed that he didn't get a chance
to hit that and this life that he lived
was not the life that he wanted uh and
he he paid the ultimate price for it
yeah dude that's sad um yeah I love that
documentary and anyone who's listen
absolutely absolutely watch it
definitely like a I mean I've told you
this story before but it happened on the
podcast [__] hell four years ago uh
but it's Coy right so uh Kristoff our
boy Mutual mutual friend of ours he's
played for djed for me for 15 years and
he told me this story on the podcast
which you can go back and listen to four
years old it's really great it's an
insight into the life of a touring DJ I
think it
was a Wednesday or a Thursday and he was
in
Argentina and the next time
that he was going to get to sleep in a
bed that wasn't in the air was Tuesday
so it was almost a full week of sleeping
on planes or
in loues or yeah in in in Vans or
whatever um this is a guy who has played
Madison Square Garden supporting Eric
prids he's got a residency this summer
at high IA I think it's every Tuesday
with Adam Bayer uh and maybe prids there
as well or maybe hoton 82 or something
as big as it gets before you get to
Absolute like insane Superstar like edge
here and of dance level and you know
from the outside it looks really
glamorous but he told me the story and
he hadn't been sleeping all that much
and he'd been like drinking and partying
and stuff like that throughout his shows
and then he had this period and he got
back and he couldn't sleep even though
he was like super super tired and he was
watching shopping channels like QVC and
and live TV shopping for some reason and
he couldn't work out why and then he
says he kind of blacks out he he has
this Blank Spot in his memory then he
came to at the local supermarket that's
24 hours it's across the street from
where my house just down the street from
where my house is in gosi in Newcastle
he came to and he was sat on the floor
of the toiletries aisle and he had one
of every different type of hair gel and
hair putty laid out around him on the
floor and he was taking little bits of
it and putting putting it on his head
scooping his hand in and like slapping
it on his head and he had this thought
in his head like yeah my hair's [__]
like I need to try all of these
different things so he's putting it on
his head and then he sort of comes to
out of this sort of fever dream and
looks around and he's like what am I
what am I doing here stands up grabs a
flet of broccoli 48 dishwasher tablets
and walks out without paying for them
gets home and wakes up the next day to
find hundreds hundreds of parcels
arriving at his front door for like
little 5-year-old girls crop tops and
toys and lawnmower accessories and like
an inflatable pool all of these
different things and he just had a like
a small psychotic break wow and then he
went to a doctor presumably a
psychiatrist he said yeah that's that's
a that's a combination of sleep
deprivation and a bunch of really really
that's psychosis right there yeah for
sure
yeah I would love to see what like his
blood work was oh yeah at that what is
running through your body that's causing
this to happen oh my God
yeah insane dude and he was saying like
you know from the outside the DJing and
you're playing and everyone's got their
hands in the air and they know the words
to your song or they've listened to it
on Spotify or they've come especially to
AA to just see you and your set and
maybe less so with a residency but
certainly when you're touring he said
the reality is that you get back to a
hotel room and you haven't eaten in
probably 8 hours and maybe you're drunk
or maybe you're not and you're alone and
it's dark and you order room service and
you sit in your room on your own and you
try and chill out and you try and wind
down and you don't and then you
eventually go to sleep and you wake up
the next day having only had a few hours
sleep because you need to get on a plane
to get to the next place to get up and
you can't remember where you are you
arrive at the venue and you sound check
and it's it's a different place with a
different club and a different promoter
but the same promoter and the same club
and the same place because it is just
over and over and over again the Guy
meets you he gives you a beer he
explains the club you soundcheck you let
the warmup DJs go on you start partying
and Away you go and yeah Chris the
people who watch him are having way more
fun than he is the best part of being a
DJ is being in the audience yeah yeah uh
so this is a really interesting story uh
my buddy Pat who you've met he's an
incredibly talented singer songwriter
here in Austin and he's uh from Ireland
and he was opening for this singer
songwriter that I used to listen to back
when I listened to Pandora um I mean
that's literally 2010 or something where
Pandora was the original algorithmic
music and one of his songs
um was so important to me like I loved
it and and then I found out that Pat was
opening for this guy his name name is
Joe Pug um and the song's called him
number
35 and I watched Pat play Pat was
incredible I watched this guy play Joe
Pug it was very good um but it wasn't
what I remember it wasn't as this thing
that I had thought it was gonna be which
is which is fine it's okay and he played
that song that I
love and then at the end
um Pat's selling merch he's selling
merch and then everyone leaves and I
walk up to him and I'm like himm number
35 I have loved that song for over a
decade
now and it the lyrics to it every part
of it was so mystical to me I was like
what what were you thinking when you
wrote that or what what is this song
about and his answer was I don't know
man I was just young and I just wrote
something and then he just kind of like
walked away and I was
like [__] like
it really isn't important to him it
really like it kind it was then a little
bit but I have made this into something
that it's important to me the lyrics in
it are incredible it's an in it's
probably one of my favorite singer
songwriter songs ever and this the guy
who made it had all he had to say was I
was young when I wrote it and I don't
really know and he just kind of fumbled
off and walked away what's the lesson
that you took away from that it's the
same thing with Cy it's like the the
experience to somebody else with your
art is
just it's usually going to be much more
valuable than your own experience which
is really crazy to think about really
genuinely as as creators
ourselves somebody definitely has taken
a Chris Williamson clip or video or
something that you have done and it is
much much more important to them than it
could ever be to you so that's probably
right but I would say from a Creator
perspective I'm trying to think if this
is right I might go out on the limb and
say that it's true I think that being a
podcaster is
probably reducing down the pain of being
a Creator about as much as it's possible
to do it you even the difference between
being a YouTuber and being a podcaster
there's so much more performance
required in doing the YouTube thing if
it's like hey guys welcome back to the
channel today I'm going to give you my
top 10 tips for doing the this thing
because you need to write a script you
need to write an outline and then you
need to do take after take after take oh
[__] I flub that line [__] that was the
wrong what was the thing that I'm
supposed to say in that and then you
come back to it so that's a level of
performatives and then if you take it
one step further and you go
to working on a nighttime as some sort
of a performer some sort of a DJ your
sleep patterns all over the place are
you actually making money during the day
do people actually care about what it is
that you're doing
there is a high price that you pay for
it and we've spoken about this before
even the guys that Vlog the the travel
vlogging stuff that they do 50% of the
trip is lived through the lens of the
camera and until you get to the stage
where you have a videographer following
you around which almost nobody do like
proportionally nobody gets there even if
you're Mike thirston and you've got you
know an amazing videographer you've got
Louis following you around and it's all
cool and you live in Dubai or you got a
villa in Mara even then you got to take
time out of the experience
to record The Experience so that it's
there and it's like okay well what I
guess in some regards you have this
really cool record on your YouTube
channel that's beautifully edited of all
of the cool stuff that you did but I
watched this video a little while ago
about how when you you're not actually
doing it is what you're saying right
you're not in the moment and there's
another there's another element there's
a study that was done on people that
take photos and when you take a photo of
a place or an experience the brain
drowns out most of the other sensory
information and actually focuses more on
the visual so it's good not only that
you have a record of it but it also
focuses your attention in sort of a
sensorial aspect down onto the visual
the problem is most of the things that
you feel about an experience are outside
of just the visual oh it's the smell
yeah of the of the guy smoking his
cigarette down the street from the
Vatican and it's the the sound of the
street it's so much more immersive so
yeah you know long story short you're
right and I think that a lot of people
take way more away from shows than the
creators do but the creators get to take
at as close to the audience as I think
with pretty much any other art form
because remember it's their curiosity
that's driving forward it's less
performative than playing songs it's
less performative than doing YouTube and
on top of that the price that you have
to pay in order to do it it's on your
terms it's your uh publish schedule like
yeah it's aggressive and there's [__]
tons and tons and tons and tons of work
to do but I think of if you were to pick
something out of the ecosystem it's the
one that's sort of the most holistic but
it's also the one that's the least viral
which is why a lot of people don't do it
yeah I mean they or they don't do it to
your level because it takes a while and
you got you know there's luck there's
Talent there's a bunch of things that
come into play as well yeah well you've
pivoted right you've changed the style
of content that you do as well and I
think yeah that was
a risk um but it was ultimately an
important thing for me to do to try and
Branch out and do different things
because I'm if people are attracted to
myself as a Creator then they have to be
attracted to actually me and I don't
want to uh do you know this this
audience capture thing um that would
just I think would ruin me here's an
interesting question do you think that
Philip DeFranco is audience
captured uh yes but he again he is repor
in
so the variability of all of his reports
um but he does much more so now he adds
in a little bit of his own life he talks
about he one time he talked about his
weight loss uh he he's talked about you
know even when he talks about his merch
and like the the importance that it
means to him it's still like part of him
yeah it's uh the ultimate audience
capture which your boy wrote about uh
Ginder
G um he wrote about nikocado avocado
that is that article I actually pulled
up on my friend's podcast the other day
I just was on his podcast talking about
audience capture and he defined it
perfectly and the way that he
described uh nicacado was as Nicholas
Perry the violinist veganist uh and then
it obviously he turns into this Glutton
because He follows his audience capture
so ultimately we do we are captured a
little bit by our audience and that's
okay okay you have to perform and you
have to provide a good entertainment
service it cannot just be simply for
yourself but at the same time you do
have to take risks and you do have to do
things that not many people are doing I
I've noticed your risks that you take
that you think aren't risks but they
genuinely are like um you will spend
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars for production yeah bringing Sam
Harrison was one of the biggest risks
that I've had recently which is so crazy
to say
like but he just has such a vehement
group of people on the internet that
really really don't like him and I've
said it [__] bunch of times after the
episode I had so much fun recording that
podcast I was like caught myself at
least twice grinning like an idiot when
I knew that the camera was on him just
really really enjoying it and being like
this is fun this is super fun and I love
experiences like that man like that is
that's what it's really about any
performance once you get into that
groove of being like oh [__] this is
amazing this is what I this is why I
love doing what I do so I just made a
video uh at the CrossFit games where I'm
lifting with two guys two other uh at
the Wall Street weightlift one yep
everyone should go and check that out on
Zach Channel yeah and I've got I haven't
gotten more comments from people being
like this is your best video I have ever
seen they're they're probably newer
viewers I have some really good ones
from like the past five years but the
reason the real reason why was dude we
were having a [__] blast I was
laughing smiling like it was I'm getting
the chills thinking about it I was like
this is why I do what I do yeah and it
can't always be like that but when it is
and you capture it it's like that's why
we do it and it makes you feel so good
hell yeah where should people go they
want to check out more of your stuff go
to uh just search z z k space t e l and
e r and the search search bar or you can
go to youtube.com/ zacker uh coach ZT is
my Instagram and then if you would like
some programming if you want to get a
stronger squat you want to get generally
strong or if you want to go into
weightlifting Olympic weightlifting
which I highly suggest you can go to
patreon.com Zack telander and if you
want to listen to some banging Tunes
search for telander on Spotify oh yeah
I've got some stuff coming out so yeah
all right man let's go to the Soho house
I'm hungry all right all right bye bye
if you enjoyed episode then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe